faut-il faire confiance au docteur g
alors dû me mohamed
vous êtes médecin gentil je vous êtes a
bien sûr fait partie de l'équipe
également
qu'est ce que vous en dites alors moi je
ne pense que ce n'est pas forcément une
question d'avoir confiance au sahara où
moi je crois plutôt en la science et
j'aimerais que le professeur raoult et
raison et ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'on se rend compte qu'il a un soutien
assez extraordinaire de la population
mais pour plusieurs raisons la première
c'est que nous et je me suis battu dans
la communauté scientifique
nous nous sommes trompés à propos du
coronavirus nous avons eu des données
chinoises qui nous ont peut-être un peu
erronée et misant du côté de donner à
l'armée on s'est trompé et le pot sahara
ou à ce genre lui ne s'est pas trompé
donc il est normal que les gens aient
plus confiance en lui puisque nous qui
est ton plutôt tranquille il ya deux
mois désormais on est catastrophés au vu
de la situation il est normal que les
gens aient confiance en question avait
que lui c'est la poupée et puis on se
perd un peu particulière semble un peu
compréhensible que les gens et plus
envie d'écouter quelqu'un qui porte de
l'espoir plutôt que les autres qui pour
l'instant n'ont pas de solution à
proposer
enfin n'oubliez pas que lorsqu'on parle
du traitement la chloroquine c'est un
vieux médicament qui a fait ses preuves
il vit trop c'est à dire dans des
éprouvettes dans de nombreuses maladies
infectieuses mais qu'il vient souvent et
dans l'immense majorité des cas a été
très décevant
lorsqu'on a cherché à faire de
l'application clinique on a eu un cas
très paradoxale avec le chikungunya ou
lorsque dans les éprouvettes ça marchait
très bien on l'a testé sur l'homme il ya
eu des effets paradoxaux
on s'est rendu compte que c'était
particulièrement dangereux finalement en
ce qui concerne la personnalité du
professeur peut-être qu'il ya un peu de
jalousie de certains il faut le
reconnaître mais ça on va la mettre de
côté look du professorat ou moi je peu
importe il un look rock ou pas qu'il
soit cache-cache mégalomane
c'est pas la question ce qu'on lui
reproche c'est ses effets d'annoncé
habituellement dans la communauté
scientifique
lorsque vous avez des avancées majeures
voulu voulait publiés dans des journaux
scientifiques avec des comités de
lecture et vous ne faites pas de vidéos
youtube vous annonce t ac façon
triomphante
j'ai trouvé le remède du coup on est
russe ça c'est problématique parce que
il est porteur d'un espoir d'un espoir à
ces extraordinaires puisque il propose
un traitement qui existe qui coûtent pas
cher que peut produire en masse et qui
peut-être pourrait sauver l'humanité je
pense particulièrement à l'acheter
afrique qui va être touchée par
l'épidémie
et dont les conséquences vont peut-être
catastrophique alors là pour l'instant
c'est partout au cours de concerts a ou
c est ce que le traitement du professeur
ferait mieux 15 notre traitement et la
difficulté des lacets que le corps des
virus même si les conséquences sont
dramatiques
les gens guérissent de façon spontanée
dans 85 % des cas et quand je vois des
personnels des politiques comme monsieur
estrosi dire qu'avec la chloroquine il a
réussi à guérir
on n'a aucune preuve que si monsieur
estrosi avait pris de la chloroquine ou
de la vitamine c les résultats ont été
différents peut-être qu'avec n'importe
quel traitement
monsieur estrosi ou tous ceux qui
clament être guéri de façon miraculeuse
par la chloroquine accordé pu guérir
spontanément et dans la population
ça va nourrir un peu la théorie de
complot on va dire mais pourquoi le
professeur article un traitement ou ne
donne pas un traitement qui coûte pas
cher et qu'est ce qui se passe en
conséquence des gens vous commencez à
s'automédiquer non franchement on a des
gens qui sont des troubles du rythme
cardiaque
car il utilise mal de médicaments et que
finalement rares plus de conséquences
négatives
donc l'enjeu est simple si le ressort à
ou à raison et j'espère que la raison
pour la france pour l'humanité et puis
aussi à titre individuel sont un peu
plus égoïste
on a tous dans notre cercle personnelle
des gens qui sont atteints du
coronavirus avec des formes plus ou
moins sévères et on espère qu'ils ont
raison et on a l'impression que la
comité scientifique est divisé entre le
professeur à outils voudrait sauver le
monde
et puis tu lises qui serait de vilaines
personnes qui voudraient pas avoir un
traitement
moi je pense qu'on doit faire preuve de
mesure en temps des soutiens politiques
médiatiques certains journalistes posent
problème
il faut que les études avant celui il ya
un petit effet négatif de l'effet waouh
c'est que en ce moment il ya des études
en cours qu'on appelle l'étude discovery
où il ya quatre bras traitement on
traite des antiviraux on donne des
antiviraux à des gens et dans un des
bras le plaqué deal sauf que désormais
les patients veulent tous être inclus
dans la zone où on donne le plaqué
nickel ne veulent plus faire partie de
l'étude est donc paradoxalement on
freine la recherche